Hello, and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
Live. I am your host, Rawkode.
Before we begin, I just wanna take a
quick moment to say thank you to Equinix
Metals. They are my employer. They are a
bare metal cloud, and they give me the
time and resources to invest in the show
and produce content that we can all learn
from together.
If you wanna check out Equinix Medal, please
use this at Rawkode dash live coupon. This
will get you $50 of compute. That is
roughly one hundred hours on our smallest instance.
Certainly enough for you to have some fun
and play with. Now today,
I am joined by my friend,
Kieran McNulty.
Welcome back, Kieran. It's always a pleasure to
have Hi, David.
So
I can hear you, though your video has
frozen
on you. Although, I think it's coming back.
So
you can you hear me okay? Yeah. Alright.
Okay.
I can. I'm just gonna prioritize my laptop,
my network.
Someone got Netflix on.
Yes.
Alright. I'll give a little bit of context
just now while you get that sorted. This
is it's turning into a bit of a
series. We're taking a look at behavior driven
development through
multiple episodes and real world application.
I have been building out or, you know,
failing to build out, but being guided by
Kieran, a get library called get sync, retina
rust that aims to provide the backbone of
get up stale operators or event driven applications.
We
kind of started
by an example
mapping session,
which was roughly two weeks ago now. We
used a middle board and in real time,
we kinda tried to discuss the application,
flesh out those requirements,
loads of stackies to add colors, very nice
guidance from keeping on how that all works.
And then we could look very briefly at,
well,
how do we store this in a get
repository? How do we how do we use
GERKIN to write scenarios and kinda give other
people, not just my own understanding of the
application, but share that with other people.
And I think we wrote half a scenario,
and then you told me to go in,
do my homework, and and do more, and
I didn't.
And then we thought, well, why don't we
just continue the series? Let's do this live.
You know, it's always a pleasure to have
your guidance because I really do. I'm really
terrible at this. So
No. No. No. Yeah. So the thing we
did last time
was is broadly speaking in this area of
discovery,
deliberate discovery.
So we sort of took time to
I I didn't know anything and you knew
a
lot.
And then maybe we added a bit during
that conversation. And I think if we'd had
more people,
we'd have had more sort of
insightful questions that that helped us flesh it
out a bit. And we came out of
that with a kind of shared understanding of
what it should do,
what we've decided that it should do. Yep.
Because we don't wanna make it too, like,
spec y, too
contract y.
But, you know, we we'd have done that
quite soon before we're gonna build it, and
we kept all understanding what we just agreed.
And I think what what we might find
is because it's been two weeks, we'll have
kind of forgotten
the context. So I guess we're gonna look
at the mirror board. We might not quite
remember what some of it means, you know,
because it's kind of scrappy notes.
So the idea is that shortly after that,
someone would capture that that conversation, and that's
where the kind of second step of
so formulation comes in where
someone you you're trying to slow the meeting
down by capturing everything in the meeting. If
you've ever tried to do that in a
meeting, you know it's absolutely
painful.
Everyone stop talking while I type this.
So you can avoid that, but then you
try and sort of dump it out
shortly after.
And then share it with everyone and make
sure you captured it right and maybe get
some feedback so that that there's a few
cycles inside that process
before and and then you take that through
to development. That's the kind of gist. So
I guess we're at that step of we're
gonna try and capture what we talked about
last time,
write it down in a way that we
think is gonna be clear. I remember you
were one of the reasons you're doing this
is to have documentation for people in the
future.
Yep. So capture it in a way where
it's gonna be clear for those sort of
future generations.
Definitely. I don't want people to run this
enough any surprises about what is is actually
happening.
So I guess we'll get up the middle
board. Let's run through that briefly, and then
we'll start putting our scenarios together.
We have our first comment as well from
someone I think we both know, Mark. Hey,
Mark. How's it going?
Alright. Let's
pop this up.
Let's see. Because I am. A little bit.
Yeah. So the to recap briefly what the
structure is, we've got and I the blue
thing is the most important things. They're business
rule.
They're things that have to be
implemented somewhere in the system. So it's really
important to understand where they are. They they
kind of they do directly map to this
the the code you're writing in a way.
Yeah. They're
they're build they're like what is
Oop. I lost you, mate.
And he's gone.
I'm still here. Alright.
Yeah. You threw something for a second there.
Oh, dear.
Yes. The the the other things
and when you're doing example
use you sort of think of it as
I'm
not
no. You're you're you're in and out, Kieran.
Your video has has has given up,
and your audio is Can hear me at
all?
Yep.
I'm just gonna check my connection just in
case.
Oh, Mark, if you sent her in the
comments, if you let me know if it's
just one of us or both of us.
My connection looks pretty solid. I've got 500
meg.
Alright. You've not frozen on me in the
last thirty seconds, so we'll continue.
What I might do
is
disconnect briefly and come back. Is that gonna
break anything?
No. No. No. You do that. I will
I'll tell jokes.
Yeah. Thanks for the comments, Mark and Wolfgang.
I think it is just Kieran's connection. I'm
not sure if there are too many Netflix
sessions going on or it just needs Maybe
it's the new m one Mac. Maybe the
networking is not very good on it. Although
it we'll see.
So this middle board then
oh, it's back already. Let's see if that's
any better. So the middle board,
the blue stickies
Our rules.
Good save. Thanks. Our rules. And then the
green cards were
examples of things that we think happen
within those rules.
The yellow, I don't remember what that was,
and the red was questions.
Yeah. So the important I don't know how
much you caught before I broke up.
So the important thing is the business rules.
They're gonna be implemented in the code.
So all of this is so everyone understands
the business rules in a in a way.
The other thing is called the feature in
this context,
but it's really just a way of grouping
the rules together into something that we're gonna
deliver as a block. So you could think
of it as, like, which things which rules
need to go together for it to be
worth
releasing it or saying or counting it as
done. You know?
So they might be the things that you
have in your backlog if you're doing a
sort of backlog driven development.
You might think, one this first rule, repositories
are cloned if not already.
We wouldn't want that if we haven't implemented
the other rules as well.
So the rules become a nice way to
break down your chunk down your work.
Mike Cohen has some acronym SPIDER
without an e
of of different ways of breaking down
big
or he says user stories because it's Mike
Cohen. Breaking down user stories into smaller ones,
and the r is rules.
So are there some of the business tools
we can implement first without the rest is
a nice way of doing it.
Okay. The others are
other stuff.
Spike path,
identity and data.
But like, one of the strategies for chunking
stuff down is to break it up by
rules. It's nice if you can say, actually
you could do these first.
And actually, maybe some of the rules could
be, this is going a bit deep. The
rules can maybe relate to feature toggles. So
say, maybe the rules could be feature toggled.
But anyway, so Yeah. To say that we've
done initial cloning of the repo and ticket
is done on our list of to do,
those three business rules are gonna be implemented.
And the way we know they're implemented is
for each rule, we came up with an
example.
At least one example.
And in third case, we had three different
examples of ways it might work. Yep.
So the examples there so that as a
developer, I can sort of say I can
I can read the example and it gives
me a better understanding of the business rule?
But also,
you know, we on the third one, we
need these three different cases to all be
true. And naturally, that'll help us test it
later.
So it helps us understand the rule, and
it helps us test the rule. But they're
only really there for the rule
to make sure the rule gets implemented. The
end game is the rule is implemented by
the software.
Okay.
That makes sense. So we identified three features.
The is there a semantic or heuristic that
says that this is one feature fail or
one scenario or multiple scenarios? Like, how how
do we then translate this to to the
language
then? I'd put it in one feature file
per feature Perfect. Sure. Initially.
But if if if it's sort of so
sometimes
later in a project, you're working on something
that's more like modifying the existing rules.
You might instead edit an existing feature file.
If that's So
because the first step for us would be
then to work on our initial clone feature
and then try to take these rules and
examples
and flash them out as full scenarios that
we can then use for documentation
and for testing.
And if you're right if you're doing this
first
and for deciding what order you're gonna do
things in. So it's to guide your own
workflow. So I'm
if if I'm working on this project, I
would think which feature am I gonna work
on next. Maybe it's this one.
As I'm working through it, maybe I'll think,
oh, okay. My first thing I need to
do is I need to implement repositories are
cloned if not already.
I'd get that going, you know, do that
sort of test driven thing. Yep. But let's
write the feature.
We'll write a feature file and then see
how it goes.
Alright. So You know, there's this thing about
writing tests first.
It's popular with the kids.
And
not with me. I've never been very good
with that. But I will I I will
try to fix my my bad habits.
So
What what one of the points of BDD
so so TDD exists, and
people tend to apply TDD at a low
level
when they're trying to work out an algorithm
or something.
One of the reasons for BDD
is to sort of encourage applying that pattern
at higher levels. This this higher level is
of a feature. So let's let's design the
feature first in a in an automatable way,
and then we'll write the code,
which is kind of TDD, but it's just
sort of phrasing it differently to make it
more likely that people do it.
And this is what we wrote last time.
Right?
It is.
Yes.
So we we slightly reworked this is a
good example. We slightly reworked some things from
the example map, and that's perfectly fine.
If you were if you're in the session
and you think of a better name,
it's it's fine to,
you know, editorialize a bit. It's kinda what
you meant to be doing is clarifying.
And then you would share this with well,
you're sharing it with me now live.
But you might you might do this writing
down outside of your repository. You might do
it in it's good to match the communication
methods that people are happy with. So it
could be a Google doc.
It could be in a field on a
like, some field on a Jira ticket.
Yep. It could be you paste it into
Slack and say, what do you guys think?
You sort of do it informally because you
wanna you're expecting people to say in some
places that's not really what we talked about
or tweak it a bit. But let's do
it the Git repo.
So you've got the the feature title. You've
got a bit of explanatory text that is
just for readers. It's not for the computer.
Yep. We've identified a rule.
We've got one example.
So what's the rule? If the directory doesn't
exist, the repository can be cloned.
So given I've got no local directory, when
I sync a Git repository, then the Git
repository is cloned.
What do you think of that one?
I'm not sure because I I don't even
remember who wrote that, if it was you
or me or a collaboration.
To me, it makes sense.
I mean, one of the things I struggle
with when it comes to ratings scenarios is
trying to understand
the the subject.
Like, you know, I think because
yeah. I I I know there's, like I
don't know if the rules are are guidelines,
but, you know, avoid avoid the term of
the user
and such.
Yeah.
And here we're using I.
I mean, is that is that that the
same? Yeah.
It's fine. You could switch it to the
passive voice if you want to.
Okay.
Given there is no local directory when the
Git repository is synced.
K. So, I mean, just try to There's
two stylistic things. One is being eye centric,
which some people really like.
Being
saying,
you can also do a sort of third
person thing where you say, when Bob syncs
his Git repository.
And then that's useful if you've got some
concept of, you know, different user personas or
maybe different types of users, like you're trying
to cater for people who are really familiar
with the system, but also you want to
think about,
you know,
James who is not tech savvy at all
and has different challenges
or people who are really familiar with it.
So if you've done that kind of user
scenario
thing that usability people like to do sometimes,
you know, returning users, new users, you could
have names and, you know, flesh all that
out.
Some people do I because, again, it makes
it feel a bit more immediate,
Whereas the passive
voice like a plural, like, Kevin, we have
no local directory when we sync.
Yeah. I mean,
There isn't a right or wrong. It's it's
I'd match what I would try and do
is match what people
would how were people talking about it in
the
in the in the
the session. So Okay. People in the session,
were they saying, when I go here, I
should be able to do this? Or were
they saying, when when they, the customers, come
to our site?
I'll try and match that.
It's probably the best.
Okay. Let's stick with I for this afternoon's
session. We also have a quick question from
Wolfgang who is asking rules and examples aren't
still the same. Yeah.
So this can happen when the you've only
got one example.
And that there's two type that one of
one of the hard things when you're writing
when you're writing a scenario is
how much detail do I need to put
in there.
So
using rules is quite important for this, to
help this. It's one of the reasons that
rules have been adopted quite a lot is
one reason for adding specifics into a scenario
is gonna be because it's relevant to the
rule.
So what's the rule about? It's about directories
and what directory existing or not means.
Mhmm.
So any detail that's about that can lead
to some questions. Right? So what does directory
existing mean?
Could it what happens if sometimes it leads
to questions. What happens if it exists but
is owned by someone else?
What happens if it exists
with a different case?
What happens
Yeah. We never really get into a lot
of we never really for
me, because of my user permissions,
but I can't create a directory with that
name
because there is one in the file system.
All of these might be technical things.
But so so one reason is to explain
the rule. I think
we could put the name of the directory
in there to make it clearer,
to make it more like an example.
Okay. It not be part of the Even
I have no directory called
something
when I sync the
yes. So, actually, that's a good question.
In Git, what determines the name of the
in your system? Is it always gonna use
the name of the repository as the folder
name?
Not quite. Did we touch about that on
the config?
No. I don't think we did.
Think we spoke about it last time, but
what we said was there there is the
concept of configuring get synced to tell it,
you know, where
the cache directory is gonna be to store
these repositories
and stuff like that. But we'd never
we what what I said was that functionality,
I don't mind being just
hard coded as sensible defaults for now and
bring configuration later.
So we haven't really said it's gonna clone
to this. But, yeah, I think realistically, it's
gonna be the name of the project.
Okay. So let's put a let's give an
example of a project name that makes it
so one reason is to make it explain
the rule better. The other reason for extra
detail is to make someone reading it understand
the domain we're operating in a bit more.
Project a okay? Or Yeah.
You you want it to be
you don't want to be too silly. Like,
if you if you make it too
abstract,
if everything's foo and bar,
it's harder to read and it's less real
to people. They don't think about their real
projects.
The project a is fine. Yeah.
Repository a b c, I think, makes more
sense than project because we're we're dealing with
get here, not not something else.
Yeah. And then so that's the context.
The action is when I sync a GET
repository,
you could either say, what is the name
of the GET repository?
Or you could say a Git repository that
would be cladding to repo a b c.
If you want to sort of defer that
config those config rules for somewhere else.
It's something like that? Yeah. If you're happy
for that, that's fine.
Or should that be a should I just
use a real repository rather than Yeah. Why
not? Like, I guess It makes it real,
isn't it? It can clone itself. So, actually,
let's just do that.
That's an organization.
Get
When I click when I click on the
get sync repository, we actually just clone ourselves
as part of the test case. Into get
sync output.
So try and have the steps at a
similar level of abstraction.
We or I would say This is supposed
be sync during the sync. Right? I mean,
sync is
Yeah. Then the repository is cloned. And I
would say either, I would say, into git
sync
or I would say
that directory.
Just depending on whether there's too many
too much repetition.
Let's do that.
Where's the temp come from?
I was just making that up.
Alright. Okay. So we're just gonna You could
put it in there, but I'd I'd put
something like
given my sync folder is temp.
But we we don't have a sync folder
yet. So
yeah. We we we would just clone it
to the current working directory. How do how
do we use that as an example? The
repository is cloned into What? The current working
directory as,
I think.
Okay. So does that mean you should mention
the current working directory in the given?
So given I
am in
in that end seems a bit funny, but
and the slash temp
directory,
and I have
what do I call get synced?
Is that what you mean?
Yeah. But now it feels a bit too
detailed, doesn't it? Because the temp the
the temp location isn't really
relevant.
K. So given Given
I have no directory called git sync in
the current working directory.
So given
I have no directory called git sync and
Is it the current working directory?
Would
would a reasonable
reader
assume we're talking about the current working directory?
I don't know. We don't have a reasonable
reader.
A reasonable future person joining the project.
I think we spoke about this last time
as well where I I was trying to
avoid bringing this up as long as possible,
but it runs as a library and it
runs as a command line application.
And I was trying to keep the
the for both?
No. They kept the library version of it
would require you to configure the the the
clone directory. So let's take in that current
let's take that current working directory concept out.
Okay.
It's not relevant to the rule,
and it's narrowing our options.
You could have something like
I don't suggest you change this, but you
could have something like, given
look at the background. Given the clone directory
is configured to be,
And then write everything with that included.
But it's it's a bit of extra stuff.
I think if I read this, if I've
got no direct to call git sync, I'm
kind of imagining there's a there's a folder.
There's like a target folder.
Is this something
we would just, like, context to set up
multiples
features or scenarios and say, hey. We are
assuming your code directory is
is set up as this.
This feature isn't available yet, so it's hard
for you to use slash tab. Like, could
would we just add that as a better
blurb somewhere?
Yeah. I wouldn't bother. No. Okay. Because it's
not about that rule. Like, maybe when we're
writing this stuff about
conf when we're
talking about configuration and how syncs map to,
which folder things get synced to, we probably
will want to include all that detail.
But for for the purpose of this, we
we don't because
all all we're really
you know, what's the rule gonna be? It's
gonna be an if statement
that that
lists some files and then fails outright. So
to understand this rule, I think we've got
enough.
Okay. So that means we just move on
to rule two?
Yeah.
I mean, I don't wanna put words in
your mind. Would would you do something else?
Okay. So Is we're never gonna get to
perfection as well, are we?
And these are living documents. They're gonna change
over time. Isn't that why you're here?
As we implement things and as as we
implement the tests, as we implement new features,
we're gonna modify these.
It's, like, quite common I think that quite
common that happens is, like, you don't mention
the folder that this is all happening in
like we've done. Right?
And then later, you realize there is a
rule that's really specific about which folder it's
in, and you have to go and add
add givens to the the other features.
But you don't
you don't you can't include all of the
detail that's needed to execute it in every
scenario.
So you've got to pick and choose which
bits are gonna be written here in the
Gherkin and which bits are gonna be implementation
details of the test I'm gonna hard code
in the test.
And and the important thing is which bits
do you think someone should read.
Like, to automate it, we're gonna have to
get the system into the state where it
knows which folder it's syncing into
and it knows what the what the direct
it's able to list that directory and stuff
like that.
But is that gonna be in the test
implementation, or is it gonna be visible to
human
readers?
It depends whether it's useful for them to
understand the rule.
Alright. Okay. And it depends whether it's important
for them, yeah, for the rule to be
validatable.
So all of the detail that you need
to understand the rule should be in the
scenario.
Okay. So the the bit that's slightly missing
for me
Uh-huh. But but it might not be missing
for most people is
in that in that previous one. Is it
obvious that it is taking the last part
of the folder name, and is that a
standard git behavior?
I think it's a standard git behavior, isn't
it? It is. If you do a git
clone
x y z, it's gonna create an x
y z directory.
I'm trying trying to do as much
extensible get defaults as possible.
And that's not a rule of our system,
so let's not worry about it. Alright. So
our second rule is if the target directory
exists
and is not a get repository,
then we exit
we enter
and exit with non zero code.
So the rule is if the target directory
yeah. If the target directory says this is
not a Git repository.
Mhmm.
Yeah.
So there's a folder at that location that
is not a git repository. Given I have
a directory called git sync that is not
a git repository.
K. Her example
is
this
kind of the same one one map that
you said that would happen that we have
a a rule with a single example. So
Yeah.
I wonder if you can think of is
there any situation where
no.
There's not a situation where it would sync
into the folder anyway.
Not if it's not a GET repository.
Like, that's our like, we we don't wanna
touch that. It's not managed by us. Let's
just leave it. It's
Scott. You you can move your not implemented
tag up to the feature if you want
to just for
So I'm a go I'll I'll just try
and take this up, and then let's, I
guess, review it and see. So I have
a that right It's worth it.
While while you're typing, it's worth mentioning that
underneath the rule and underneath the example, you
can put free text.
So between the the rule and the example
keyword and between example and given,
you can put some paragraphs of explanatory stuff
if it's useful.
So, you know, you can flesh these things
out quite a lot.
Yeah. So what's the non CLI specific bit
of that of the then?
If you're talking about the library
Well, I was about to type then I
crashed and I'm like, well
What does the library do?
It would return an header object or type.
Alrighty. So
then I then the repository should not be
synced.
It'll be cloned.
Then
it should be cloned.
Makes sense? Yeah. And you could put
so there's there's a user interface thing creeping
in.
You could put
and an error reported
or something like something generic like that.
If it's, like,
if it's important
business
if it's important to the business rule that
an error is reported rather than the error
just being a nice thing to do for
users.
So the distinction there is, did someone who
cares about the business say, we need and
then we need to definitely know it didn't
work.
Or is that just a nice thing we're
gonna do because we're nice to people and
print out nice error messages?
Yeah. I I I think what I want
peep like, if I try to put on
my I'm about to consume this library or
CLI application as an external user, The most
important for me to get back out of
this file would just be that I know
that directory is not gonna be mutated, modified,
blown away. Yeah.
I don't know if that then covers that
enough. That's a common mistake. Right? Is that
so a
feedback thing in in bad examples is, like,
people would just put then I should get
an error message.
And they won't capture.
The directory should have been
cloned over.
My data should have been preserved. They sort
of missed the the actual side effects and
they focus on the UI, is, like, getting
that getting error message.
So should I maybe be a bit more
explicit here? And it's it's not that we
don't clone anything. It's that that existing directory
is left untouched or
something.
Yeah. If you think that's important, I'd
base it on
understanding the business domain, whether that's an important
part of the rule.
Then?
Like, it might be you've had a history
of this application
destroying your existing data, and everyone mentions it
in every scenario that and all the data
should be preserved.
Because these are for people, it's always contextual
with the audience.
Yeah. So the important thing in the given
is that the directory called GitSync,
which is not a Git repository.
So you can either put that in the
in one line or you can put, like,
a new line in and.
K.
I put either it or git sync
between and and is.
And the final one then,
it is a directory.
Is a get repository.
Multiple examples. So
Mhmm. Let's see how we go on with
this one.
So as we now we're
now we've got a few.
If there's a step
that is really similar to a previous step
and it's just like a couple of words
different,
just use the wording from the original step
or change the change the previous step
Just for the automation. If the if the
same thing said two ways and it means
something slightly different,
even if it's the same underlying step, I
wouldn't there.
You see what I mean?
I don't know if that makes sense.
Okay.
But
something is wrong. It doesn't match the remote.
So something is not captured in our middle
board.
Mhmm.
Okay. No. We do capture here.
It's just our rule here is, like, if
the directory is get doesn't match the remote
dot colon, but then we actually have an
example where we we did it at colon.
So, like, the rule was probably just
I don't know if it's a rule or
or what, but this is basically it's just
saying that we have a directory and it's
a Git repository, then there's a few things
that can happen.
Mhmm. A rule specifically is does that mean
we got something wrong?
The rule is don't clone it if it's
But we do yeah.
Like, oh, the origin points to the right
URL, so we assume it's the right one
and we start reconciling.
Yeah. Often, if there's a rule, like, you
can only do x if y, you'll have
an example where you can do an example
where you can't do.
There'll be a happy and a sad. In
this case, we've got two sads and a
happy.
Okay. So what does that mean for a
rule here? Because I I that means I
probably shouldn't be saying that
we don't call in in the rule. So
as
this isn't a rule anymore, is it?
It is because there's an if at the
start. So we don't if
x, then we don't y. Right. Okay. You
can still have an example where we do.
You can rephrase it. I I this.
Do not clone it. And then you still
need the rule should be like an algorithm.
So you put f at the start because
you're a developer.
Uh-huh.
Some people I think
non developers often will put the thing first
and then say if.
Just match what someone said.
So
well, let's
I I just wanna make sure I get
it. I I don't know if I'm complaining
about semantics. They're not really important. Right? But
the rule here is if the target directory
doesn't exist, and then we have an example
of what happens. And then here,
we probably shouldn't say there's errors. Instead, we
should just send if the target directory exists
and it's not a GET repository. And then
down here, we're saying, okay. If it does
exist, then it has a GET repository. And
then we have other examples.
Yeah. But you don't have the rules.
If the target directory exists and it's a
Git repository,
what's the rule?
Well, that's what I was saying. Should. Here.
There's there's no rule anymore.
Yeah. It needs to be a rule.
Okay.
So as the target directory doesn't
exist Exist, we can clone.
Okay. Clone.
Maybe a bit too example. Hang on. So
what is the rule?
Maybe we can collapse them a bit. Alright.
I think I split them out in the
example mapping.
So that first one that first example is
the the sort of happy path, isn't it?
The happiest path.
Yeah. So
if if if there's no local state, then
we just we clone it, we're off. That's
it. Reconciliation starts. There's nothing to worry about.
So is that is that not in a
rule? Is this just an example of this
feature?
Yeah. Maybe.
Just take the rule out for a moment.
Maybe someone in the chat can suggest what
the rule is there.
The rule is it okay. The rule is
it clones it into the right place.
But is that not just an example? Do
do we need an explicit rule there?
I guess I'm back to this.
Maybe this is the same kind of question
that Wolfgang asked earlier. I'm not sure.
When the rules and examples map directly like
that. It should be not just to met
the rule. And then when we have multiple
examples, then maybe the rule can be enforced
and we structure the the scenarios a little
bit differently.
Yeah. I've been trying recently not to omit
the rule. I wonder if the rule is
something
for that first one, it's something like
it gets cloned into the right place.
It works. Like, oh, your software can work.
That mean, is that a real
I don't know.
If the if the
if the repository has not been synced,
we create a new folder.
Not sure how I feel about that. Okay.
Is it easy to put the examples for
this, and then we'll group them into rules?
Yeah.
Let's do the examples and then see if
we can
and then see if our rules reflect what
we had in our example. So so the
first example, happy example is, here's what happens
when you sync.
The second example,
I think these maybe these two
are about if there's something else on disk
in a colliding
folder name,
we don't clone.
Alright. Let's get the exam let's see the
sample center, and then we'll try and we'll
try and reverse engineer the rule.
What we're seeing here is a local directory
as the wrong get repository.
So
we have a dot get directory. It has
an origin configured,
but the URL does not align with what
we were expecting. So we have Yeah. I
like I like the example title you've given
there
because the detail is gonna be in the
steps.
But but we're illustrating a general case.
Bet I got something right. So
we have a directory called git sync, and
it is a git repository.
And it has Use the word but there.
So but is the same as and,
but I think it reads better.
No. No. The second one.
But But it has an
has a remote
called
origin
that points to a different
repository.
Because we're gonna name the repository in the
when step. Why don't you name the repository
in this step?
Why don't you give the explicit URL?
And it points to
parity.
Yeah.
Let's see. So just a different repository.
I thought it was maybe to some other
name. I don't wanna cause any confusion. So
Mhmm.
Alright. So we've got our given and the
but. And then
when
I sync the and then but let's just
copy this.
Oh, come on, computer.
Repository,
then
the directory
is left untouched,
and nothing is going.
Mhmm. Now they seem the same because they
got the same outcome. So it's like
there's something there that isn't a clone of
the thing we're trying to clone.
Alright. Let's get the other two, and then
then we'll Alright. We'll we'll chase the we'll
we'll try and pull that set a bit
more.
So we've got the has origin wrong URL,
has no origin. Right? So this is pretty
much gonna be
can you have a look and look at
them by names per example, or would it
be a new example?
A new example. Even though the example title
would be the same. Is that okay?
Why is it the same?
It's still the wrong get repository,
or should we be more specific for sorry.
Yeah.
Just say it doesn't have a remote. It
doesn't have an origin remote.
Okay. There actually is a local
local.
Okay.
Let's I'll fix this first. So we have
a the retro call gets sent as a
git repository,
but
it has no remote call It did. Origin.
Yep.
So the example is local directory
with raw with no origin remote.
You don't have an Example title isn't mandatory,
by the way.
Alright. Okay.
Would I keep calling this local directory or
would I say local
get
repository
has no like, does that make it more
correct? The local
GET repository
has no remote Local clone, local checkout.
Yeah. Local
local clone. Yeah. That makes sense to me.
Local clone has no remote And then local
yes. This is clone in the one above.
Yeah. So local clone
has incorrect
remote for origin.
And remote
incorrect URL for
origin.
Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Yeah. That that So I think they
grouped together now, don't they? So
You wanna keep going. Let's keep going. Let's
keep going. Well, the last one is that
it works, the happy path. So do we
I think you're right and that we've said,
okay. These are very, very similar. This is
the rule. It's a different happy path.
It's a different happy path. Right? It's a
happy path where there is a local checkout,
and we're gonna skip.
So it's a different outcome. Different context and
a different outcome.
So local colon is the correct
is
has the correct
origin remote.
But given I'm just gonna Yeah. So maybe
it's not a happy path. It's that with
Okay. I'm gonna have this directory as a
good repository,
and
it has
remote.
Hold on. Is it also completing from the
other thing?
With this being on the end, the Depending
on your idea.
Well,
if you look at line 34,
we've already phrased this a different way.
Like,
that structure
is something we can use again
to be consistent with how we Yeah. To
change the repository.
Because I don't call origin points there. Yeah.
You're right.
So then when I sync those repository
and You need to change the URL on
on
the built.
Right. Thank you.
Then it colon repository.
No. No. No. It doesn't used
up here. No. No. It doesn't.
It doesn't come in repository.
Don't tell me how my software works. Right?
Okay. You're right. It
then it
reconciles. I don't know what that means yet.
Okay. And the but in this one is
an and because it's not it's not surprising.
So I tend to use but when it's
like, here's the thing that's gone wrong.
Yeah. Highlight. Is
this this but?
Now
let's refactor. Does
we do we need to say
it's a Git repository if it has a
remote
for a reasonable reader?
So for me Could we skip it? Maybe
this is the mistake I'm making.
But
Zest to me is something
I implement as a step and the codes
test they say that says I need to
create this I need to make this a
Git repository. Yeah. Yeah.
But you could always do it manually when
you're setting up the origin, couldn't you?
You know?
K. So does that mean first we move
move So so decide on readability
first.
Local clone called get synced. That's the language
we used earlier.
That's nice, isn't it?
Here.
Have a
local colon. Call get sync.
It explained if it's the wrong one? A
directory and a local colon. So
Which makes it kinda makes sense.
I I think kinda get
I
I I like local clone. I think that's
in most of the examples that we have
here. It makes sense to me. I know
that it's a get repository. I know that
I have an orange I have a remote,
and I can inspect it. So yeah. I
think that language works well.
So so just when we got to that
last example,
it's like and the system carries on to
the next step
to reconciliation.
Right?
Which which made me realize we haven't really
captured in the previous ones that we bail
out.
Where
we said nothing is is left untouched and
nothing is cloned, we need to sort of
say
we stop.
And and and the the clone fails or,
you know, some what whatever you think sounds
best that makes it clear that it doesn't
then proceed to start reconciling that.
I mean, we don't
do anything here except say it's cloned. We
don't really mention.
So
Maybe maybe that's not important.
Maybe it's just the director is left on
top.
Yeah. I feel like we need something that
captures the fact that it's not an exception,
is it? But if it's an error comes
back
or the CLI, you know, exits.
Yeah. I mean, that's one of those weird
system y things. I never know how to
create a phrase
when it comes to these scenarios.
Well, I mean, do you have an idea?
Are you trying to tease something out of
me here or no? Okay.
Then
And an error happened. And and and an
error is something
like that. Do it bad yeah. Keep puts
me bad in.
And
And we'll fix it later.
The clone fails?
What's this bit called? Bootstrap?
Yeah. There we go. Bootstrap. There is.
I think it's it's header.
Yep.
Yeah. And then put that in the places
that
it's good to try and take stuff out.
Take out the nothing is cloned.
Then
what's the then? Nothing is cloned, maybe. Bootstrap.
Complete.
What we're saying here is that there are
two states of bootstrapping.
Either we're gonna complete or we're gonna enter.
That, to me, is a very definitive, hey.
I've got a some optional return type here.
Yeah. Okay. So put that in the
other happy path as well.
Yeah.
And on that last one, let's use the
word already
in there
just for clarity.
So scroll down again.
Make you ping around.
Here?
And it already has a remote
on on the yeah. There.
Something like that. You know?
But isn't that what we define with the
I have a local clone.
Not
you know, unfair from that. Okay.
Yeah. Put it in the example title then
maybe.
Already local clone already has the correct origin.
I I don't
can you try and articulate the value of
that already? It's over what we have. Yeah.
If because
no. Okay. Leave it out. I'm easy. So
let's see if can put some rules in.
It seems like there's a rule for the
second and third the
second and third ones. These ones. Yeah.
The rule is if we have a local
Like
existing
local
clone has to
have the correct
the
or
isn't
correct.
Is that a rule?
No. It's not a rule yet. Then header.
Is a rule?
Yeah. Or you could put it like, if
we have a local clone, the rim the
remote has to be correct.
Oh, okay. Yeah. If we have If you
already have a local clone, then the remote
has to be The origin
remote
must be
correct.
Yeah. Sounds good. Means
that comes in. And now the indentation here,
does that does should this example move above
the rule? Does
So once you start adding rules, the indentation
doesn't matter.
So if you want that to not be
in the rule, you should move it up.
But I think maybe it's in the rule.
Okay. Yeah.
This is all about local clones.
Yeah. And this is just the correct clone.
You're right. Okay. And what so what was
what are the rule less ones up top?
No local directory and not a GET repository.
So the rule is don't clone if
don't clone if there's a clash with an
existing non GET directory.
Do we need a rule for the first
two?
You don't have to.
They're just sort of useful sometimes
because you got to if you think it's
obvious,
you you you you could maybe go on
the side of leaving out the example title
and putting the rule title in if you
wanted to make sure you already have the
rule always have a rule.
I think what is kinda making sense to
me is
the first two
well, the first one's what I would expect
to happen most of the time. The second
one is a very explicit
one rule, like, hey. That's a directory. It's
not gonna be positive. There's no ifs and
buts there. And then the third one, I
feel it should have a rule because, yeah,
they're they're different forks in that code path.
Like, it's like, hey. We actually need to
check a whole bunch of things for this
rule to be true. So So so think
about it this way. This think about two
different types of rules.
Some rules are constraints and things you're not
allowed to do, and that's what we've got
so far in our rule. It's like,
you're not allowed to do. Here's here's something
that would cause a problem. So we've got
two examples of the problem and then the
sort of happy version of how we resolve
it. Mhmm. But there's another type of rule,
which is like an enabling thing. What how
is the thing actually operating?
So that that first happy path, what are
the rules behind it?
Is that we clone
we'll clone the remote repository to local disk
if we can.
So we could write a rule like that.
We could those two examples could go in
a rule. It's like,
well,
part of the beach trapping is we clone
the repository.
What do we have in the mirror board?
I had an idea there. I'll I'll go
to the mirror board in a second. So
if Yeah. Go on. As the
what if we what's the words I'm looking
for? I'm failing.
As a rule to specific here, as a
rule
that
if something exists on the desk, we won't
destroy it.
Is that a rule that then captures this
one too rather than this very specific rule
about the remote being great?
Yeah. Yeah. That's a good rule for us
first two, is that we're gonna preserve any
colliding
folders.
So as a rule,
I'm gonna put Again, the the rules kind
of the rules kind of
the
the things you call a business rule and
the things you just write as part of
the software depend on the the business
priorities, don't they?
So you're gonna write this whole system.
Is it a business priority that it doesn't
clobber the local data? Maybe it is. You
only really find that out in the real
conversations with stakeholders.
I think that's what what I'm thinking. Was
like, the reason I want this documented is
I I don't ever wanna be in a
position where we just where someone runs us
and we destroy something they have locally.
Well, the rule is if there's a local
directory, we're not we're not gonna touch it.
We're just gonna leave it unless there it
fits the criteria
which we have here.
Yeah. Maybe there's a Think of the rules
like
the rules are kind of like acceptance criteria.
These are the these are the things that
if we implement them, the business is gonna
be happy. Business is you in this case.
But they're the things that will make the
system correct if they're implemented.
There's loads of other stuff. There'll be much
smaller
decisions we have to make about how it
operates.
But it's like the reason we're writing these
in this document is these are the ones
that are at they're at that business tech
engagement level where non tech people have to
be able to see what the system does.
Okay.
We yeah. If if a local directory exists
with the colliding name
or, you know,
we on the side of
safety.
Every local directory
exists,
we must
confirm
correct configuration or something.
What
what I heard you say was that it's
really important to preserve the existing data.
Preserve it and show an error.
But we fail early. You know, one of
these things.
We don't proceed.
Yeah. I think I think there's something there.
I'm not really sure what, though.
Let's put this side by side for a
moment. So
I think where my head is trying to
guide me here is that these can both
be articulated as a single rule with these
all being examples of how to proceed.
And what the rule I'm trying to explain
is, like, okay.
If we have a local
colliding
directory
and
additional
checks must be made before
writing before
it's taking control of the the the word
the thing. So
If you have a local existing directory,
it must be a correct Git clone.
It must already be
but
then I I I would probably try and
break it out into more rules. I think
your instinct is to collate more than mine
is.
Right. Let I guess it's not
not really that important. Like,
guess that's just another thing I've got in
my head. Right? These these these are 11
documents. These can change over time. In fact,
the the title of this episode was 11
documentation with BDD. So, like, I don't need
to get this right now. I just need
to have a really good base understanding. And
then as I actually start to write the
code, I may start to I
may start to pull out more of those
phrases, rules, guidelines,
and my understanding improves.
Yeah. And I think the thing
we may be missing, if you scroll up
a bit to the top of the feature
Yep.
Someone's reading about git repository bootstrapping.
We maybe need to have a rule there,
which is like, we clone it to the
local disk on first bootstrap if this folder
doesn't exist. Maybe that's the rule that's it
captures the first.
Like, there's some you you wanna write that
down somewhere.
We're actually we do we do a we
do a git clone.
Does that need to be said?
I mean, the feature is
I mean, we're calling a bootstrap, but the
the feature is
we're gonna
yeah. We're gonna
interns joined.
Your interns joined the company. So read these
in order. This is the first thing they're
reading.
Wording is hard.
The
the only reason I'm pushing this in this
direction is I want the symmetry of everything
being in a rule, but it's okay if
I do it. It's not really gonna affect
anything.
Because I have seen people,
like, grappling for rules.
Okay. So I would would on the side
of having the having the stuff in the
rule description and not having an example description.
Hello?
What's the thing we actually do? We claim
the thing.
We claim the local
we claim the local repository.
No. I thought we were kind of in
a position where if there's one rule and
one example, then we'll met the rule and
just go with the example.
I I thought that was kind of the
the heuristic we'd adhere to there. But then
you were saying, well, you want them all
to have a rule. But
if the rule and the example are the
same, should we not just have met the
rule?
I mean, that's just still a rule. It's
just it's just codified as an example. That's
kinda where my Yes. And why not put
the rule in? Because they're it's same. What
is this rule for?
Just so we've got everything on the rule
level, because the rules are rules are the
important thing.
We're going down the rabbit hole. Let's stop
let's stop. Okay.
So we've got I'm happy I'm really happy
with this. I think this Yeah. Explains
our bootstrapping process where we either
you start in with a clean stateless directory
and we start to clone the get the
things we take under management of get sync
and so the directory. And there are rules
as existing state exists of how we can
bring that under get sync management. And we've
codified that we need a more code origin.
It has to point to the right directory.
Otherwise, we wanna exit the bootstrap. Like, to
me, that is that seems
pretty complete
in my Mhmm. Yeah. For that bootstrapping.
The question is, like,
what would happen next?
The reconciliation.
But this is a deliverable. Right? When you
when you bootstrap a thing, you've got a
lot you've you're guaranteed
to either have an error message.
Yeah. I have a correct term.
Yeah. I mean, I I that's well, actually,
I think that's actually
retroactively
describes the existing behavior.
Yeah. You know, we do have Rust code
here
that calls our repository.
You know, there's some authentication I'm gonna omit
for now.
But it does
try to open it, so it checks if
it exists,
and
it checks the remote URL, which is hard
coded to look for the origin. You know?
This what Rawkode does right now.
Go back to the feature for a minute.
There's something we can talk about. So
you would we talked a bit last time
about what what level of the system you'd
test this at.
Okay. And you've kinda got a three level
system that simplify it. You've got
Git
provided by someone else.
You've got your library,
and you've got a command line application.
And I think we said last time, you
wouldn't
try and
basically, the way you choose to test it,
the the the the testing setup you you
try for your automation is going to constrain
where the rule gets implemented.
It's one of reasons I like rules in
there.
So
what's the one rule we've got? Can you
put it make it visible?
Scroll up. But yeah.
If you have a local clone, the origin
remote must be correct.
Now some of these examples
might be implemented in
Git itself already.
Your your Git library might error
when we try and do some of these
things.
Mhmm.
Like, if it already has an origin, you're
trying to clone into it, it might say,
what the hell are you doing?
So if we test your library and get
together,
some of it might be implemented already by
get, and some of it might be implemented
by your library and sort of pre checks.
And you're kind of if you're kind of
fine either way,
then a good place to test this is
at the library level.
Right?
Yep. Because that means you're you're not opening
yourself up to the possibility that the rule
is implemented in the CLI application.
You guarantee it's either in your library or
it's a need to get thing that you're
catching and handling nicely.
Yeah. I think that's where I want most
of my testing to happen, not on the
CLI itself. The CLI is really just a
wrapper around the library functions. So definitely.
Yeah. So so just to pause on that
conversation for a second.
The bit we've just done, we would then
share it with the people we've talked to,
get feedback,
massage it.
Now we're at, like, architecture day.
We're gonna build it now,
And we're talking about where we're gonna test
it. So
this stuff about the origin already existing, we
don't care. The way we're designing the tests,
we don't care if your library reads the
origins,
checks it's right,
or if your library just tries to do
the action and catches an error from Git,
we're fine either way. Yeah? Mhmm. So that
gives you some freedom
to to
to do it. But we'll know for sure
that the
we're not relying on the CLI implementing the
rule.
It's it's implemented to the library. That's pretty
that's pretty strong.
So I think we should automate all of
these tests at the library level.
Mhmm.
And
with git
real git.
And then we'll have to see how slow
Flake is.
So it's using lib git. It just it
doesn't shell out to, like, the git executable.
Mhmm. But the get executable is just a
wrapper around lub get anyway. So it's at
it should be relatively fast provided
I mean, it is actually going to clone
these repositories.
So Yes. And you might
so
you might need to look at that and
then say, maybe I should change it to
local git repositories
on the same box
if if the network speeds are slow. So
I'd look at that as you go. Yeah.
Now in another situation, if you maybe had
a web app, right, where it has
a logic layer and some database
I mentioned this because the because of the
audience.
That's a different situation because in that situation,
you might not be happy if the stuff
is implemented in the database.
You may be,
but you might not be happy if if
the key business rules are implemented as database
constraints or triggers because there's this feeling in
future you might use a different database. Like,
I don't wanna move from Oracle to Mongo
and then realize all my business rules are
in the Oracle.
Yeah.
I I want to to know they're in
that layer. So in that case, you would
deliberately test it without the real infrastructure
as the first test. The first rigorous test,
you test it with a fake database.
Mhmm. And then you would know that all
the rules are implemented in your your core
business layer.
Whereas you're happy with this being very tied
to Git. Right?
Yes. I am very happy with it being
tied to git. I think I have say
Otherwise, we'd have for the next five years.
Yeah. There'd be some, like, abstraction layer of
VCS
interface, you know. Yeah. I mean, I could
call it commit sync and, like, abstract abstract
that a way to work with CVS or
an SVN for Mercury or whatever. But, really,
I'm quite happy to tie this into kit.
So
So the only concern you've got you need
to worry about is performance. So that's the
only place we might cheat some things.
So I would test all of these at
the library level. Now the the first question
I have is, if all of these are
validated already at the library level, which ones
would you then need to rerun through the
CLI to be happy the CLI works?
Let's look at them from the top and
see.
Let's imagine they're all validated in the library
already.
Uh-huh.
So that first one,
what would we be testing if we then
also tested it through the CLI?
Nothing?
Well, you're still testing something. You're testing the
CLI calls the right function on the library.
That's all you test testing. Right? That's all
you'd be validating is, like, your CLI
does in it does the right command to
the library.
Yeah.
I guess. So so that might be one
we want to test. So you could put
a tag on that one
saying we wanna test this happy path through
the CLI.
Yeah.
We can you can you can be a
bit agnostic and say, like,
super important that
UI
because it then if you want web interface
as well, maybe we test this one through
the web interface as well.
True. I do plan on compiling this to
WASM and running it in a browser. So
Yeah. So that so that would that would
test the the button on the web page.
When I click it, it calls the right
thing in the library.
Okay. So by adding this to the list
of things we're gonna verify through the full
stack, we're getting a bit of confidence about
that. And the second one,
what what's the interaction between the CLI and
the library here? It's the same command.
And then I don't think I follow.
Okay.
So
I'm talking specifically the boundary between your CLI
layer and your library layer. What's what's the
interaction?
And I want us to cover enough tests
that we validated all the different interactions
without too much duplication.
Okay. So the So the only difference
have
we talked about what what what changes between
running get sync of the CLI application rather
than consuming it as a library in your
own code,
really, I think the only thing
that we would need to test is that
the CLI is gonna provide configuration.
Yeah. But it's not part of this feature.
Yeah.
Like, I don't think there's anything
the CLI, in this case, in the simplest
form is just gonna be a mapping to
library functions. It's not really gonna do anything
else. Yeah. It's just like
control a remote control for the library. Right?
Yeah. Exactly. So all we need to look,
which is really common,
the UI layer is just gonna send some
commands to the back end and look inspect
some return values or handle some errors.
So
in that first one, we're checking that it
sends the right command,
tells the library to do something. And we're
kind of checking that it's
well, we're not checking yet, but we're assuming
it's looking at the return value that says,
yes. I've done it. Yep. So in the
second one, local directory is in the Git
repository. It's the same command,
but in this case, there's an error.
So maybe you wanna check that as well.
The CLI handles errors that come from the
library
Okay. And exits with a non zero exit
code.
Right? Yep.
Are there any exam are there any examples
that do anything different?
No. They're
they are all checking that return value as
a library, really.
Yeah. But would I check as features CLI
instead?
You know, because we don't need to test
those other ones with the CLI.
So I think from what you've said, if
those first two run correctly through the CLI,
I believe the others will all behave correctly.
Gotcha. Okay. Given that we've given we've run
them all given we valid if we validated
them all at the library,
we only need to test those two through
the CLI.
And this is a really important pattern because
it's the thing in the web world, you
know, this is where people test every scenario
through the web interface. But really, all the
web interface does is it calls one service
and it shows the value that comes back
on the screen.
So this kind of thinking about what what's
different in each case really helps us narrow
down the end to end tests.
So by tagging these these two CLI, I'm
confirming that CI knows how to handle a
successful bootstrap and an error bootstrap. Like, those
calling those two functions and handling the return
types. And that's that's kinda what I want
the confidence with that tag. Right? If I
understand it right. Yeah. Yeah. And there isn't
anything else that it does. All the other
scenarios where it's called it tells it to
clone something, and it either gets an error
message or a success message back.
So running those through CLI
tests
aren't gonna be useful.
So in your Okay.
Yeah? Yeah. It makes sense. I was I
was kinda really confused and lost when you
were talking about the CLI tag, and I
didn't know where we were going and then
It's not a magic tag or anything. It's
just something you've you've come up with. Right?
It was just that one that where you
said, no. We don't need to test those
and that's why. I realized, oh, like, the
way that we test the mapping works is
by packing one successful one error and we
know that it's been handled. That that that
completely makes sense to me now. I got
it. Yeah. Good.
Because because an alternative would be to test
everything for CLI, not test everything for the
library.
That would give you confidence that the library
works.
Mhmm.
It
you slightly lose some confidence that maybe some
of this stuff is implemented in the CLI.
Now
because your CLI layer is quite thin, that's
maybe not a concern for you, but you
can sort of imagine in
in a more complex app or in a
website,
people might put all the logic in their
controller layer or they might put all the
logic in the JavaScript.
So this the practice of testing a lower
level first really comprehensively
at your kind of application interface layer,
application service layer,
it is really valuable because it it guarantees
to you that your core
model
implements the business rules.
And that's bulletproof then for for any
you know, if you write a web UI
that doesn't actually hand handle the error messages
that come back, that's fine. It won't be
a good user experience, but the kind of
Yeah. The the directory will have been left
untouched.
So that kind of thinking about where to
where to apply tests
really helps constrain your architecture.
Yeah. Makes a lot of
So you would run Cucumber once with a
world where
everything's going through the library.
That will work.
I've used this Rust one. Sorry.
And then you'd run it again
with a different
set of automation
with the at just running the ones that
are tagged at CLI.
I just wanna I'm gonna see if I
can just get this to run enough so
that it tells me it's not implemented.
I did try to implement some of these
tests, and I'm just gonna
Yeah.
Comment them all out for now.
So world is the shared state
between scenarios?
Yes. So the the this library has I
mean, I could have called that in if
I wanted, but that's yeah. It's called world,
and then we can configure a new world
with an empty state, and then we define
the steps using power matching and then attach
that to functions.
So I'll comment all over for now, and
we should just see, I guess,
a list of scenarios unimplemented.
The the Rust library actually seems really, really
good, actually. I've been quite impressed as I've
been thinking with it.
The the thing a lot of cucumbers are
missing is this is a way of running
the same features at different levels of automation
as part of one execution. So has that
and has for a while. But and there's
some talk of bringing it to the rest
of Cucumber, but what you tend to have
to do is
explicitly run Cucumber twice with different config files,
different configurations,
which is alright because you've got the kind
of fast in memory stuff
and slower end to end stuff.
Oh.
Yeah. I think my
look at to
that's another problem with dynamically linking. But
Let's see if that I mean, this add
the reinstall flag to that. Yeah.
Try it one more time.
And I think so if we were to
say, like
yeah. I'll need to fix that. I'll maybe
stick in a container from just remove remove
this weird host stuff completely.
So my next steps then
would be
to implement
well, I've already got the feature. So to
connect up the testing
for this to make sure it behaves the
way that we want, and then we would
come back and we would write the scenarios
for the
for the reconciliation loop.
Yeah. The sort of
TDD way of doing it.
Imagine you haven't written the code.
You would
I think, you've got a tag that doesn't
run the things that aren't implemented. You'd have
just the first scenario not implemented, and you
just read what it each step, you'd automate
step by step.
That really guides my workflow when I'm
working on stuff. You know? The first one,
I'd
I'd automate the first scenario. It would fail.
So look at the first scenario again. If
you pop open the
so I'd I'd I'd automate this first. Right?
So the the first step, I would have
something that checks there's no file called there's
no directory called git sync in the current
folder. I do that as a check
rather than deleting it if it exists.
So I'd I'd set the current working directly
to directory to some temp folder.
I'd check there's no file there.
I would call
I'd call the method that doesn't exist yet
when I sync the blah blah blah repository.
And then I'd run Cucumber and it would
tell me there's no method called
in the library called sync, and I'd go
and implement it. I was kind of hoping
I'd be able to show that actually.
I just I've blown away the target directory,
so I'll give that a minute and we'll
we'll see. But yeah. That makes sense. But,
yeah, I'd basically do TDD until the first
scenario passes and then I'd maybe think about
committing and make myself a cup of coffee.
Yeah. I think we discussed this in the
last steps towards a couple of weeks ago
as well. It's like this
because there's not a lot of business logic
here, I am relying heavily on get. There's
not really a lot of unit tests for
me to write here. This this as an
integration project that needs to be tested, I
think, in this way.
Yeah. I mean, you could go down this
whole route of having
value objects for everything.
And and
the testing strategy this acceptance testing strategy
is is from your library down. It checks
the library, does everything. Doesn't have anything to
say about the quality of the library.
Yeah. That's that's always still up to the
professionalism of the developers because
below that acceptance test level, we do get
into the
the arena of developer tests where developers are
deciding what tests to write. Mhmm. And that's
just up to the team.
The the value of acceptance test is you
do have some testing that is at that,
like, business delivered boundary,
and you you start moving towards
the the more you do this kind of
example mapping and then writing things down and
then automating the test based on it, the
more trust you get where people
trust that the things in the document have
all been checked automatically.
And and manual testing and acceptance testing can
focus on the things that we forgot to
talk about,
stuff around the borders,
stuff that you only see when it's real.
You know?
So you could you could automate those steps
against your library, get it working,
and then you could all you could either
oh, nice. Yeah. There we go. That's what
I wanted.
Yeah. Okay. So the first thing is, well,
let's do this on the next stream.
Yeah. Yeah.
So I'd I'd get the first scenario passing
with the library. I'd then, depending what time
of day it is
and how I feel, I'd then either
hook it into the CLI and get those
tests working, or I'd sort of progress through
all the other scenarios on the library. But
but hopefully by the end, I've got all
of these things passing in the library. I've
got two things passing in the CLI.
I hit commit. I commit the scenario with
the tests, with the code.
Here's or, you know, if I write it
afterwards, I squash it so it looks like
I did it in the right order.
Nice. That's my PR.
Yep. Awesome.
Feature done. Happy with that. That was good.
Good place to end then.
Yeah. I think if we got another one
of these scheduled, I'll teach you a little
bit of Rust and we'll work to implement
some of this together. That'd be really good
fun.
And then we can have we'll hopefully tackle
the
Delete all my code. Yeah. And we can
retreated it. Now you know how it works
in your head.
Right. Okay. Yeah. Fine. You don't have to.
Maybe just comment to all or put it
into backup dot r s or something. What
I will do is because we're at a
pretty good stage now is I will commit
as impicious.
We'll speak afterwards. We'll get something else scheduled
where we Yeah. We actually write the test,
connect up the steps,
really handle that libraries to allow and tag
and what that looks like.
And I think that's pretty awesome. I'm really
happy with that. Cool.
Alright. Great.
Well, oh, well, I mean, as always, Kevin,
you've got a lot of knowledge and it's
great to be able to extract it from
you and thank you for sharing it with
me. No worries. If anyone watching wants to
know more,
get in touch.
Yeah. Kieran McNulty on Sorry?
I'll come and do it at your company.
Okay. Definitely.
Yeah.
Alright. Well,
thank you again, Kieran. I'll speak to you
afterwards. We'll get something scheduled. If you enjoyed
that, you know, drop something in the comments.
Let us know if there's anything that we
you want to see us cover from a
BDD scenario, then obviously, we'll try and do
something on the next episodes. And of course,
out to Kieran if he can come and
help you with your own domain.
He's a wise man.
Thanks. Alright. Thanks a lot. I'll speak to
you again soon. Have a nice day. See
next time. Bye.